♪ ♪
>> Greg: WELL, A CANDIDATES
RAGE KEEPING VOTERS ENGAGED PETE
.RESEARCHERS SHOW VOTERS FROM
ACROSS THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
FAKE NEWS STORIES FROM PHONY
CANDIDATES, WHICH IS AN AWFUL
LIKE CNN'S COVERAGE OF
JOE BIDEN.
AM I RIGHT?
PARTICIPANTS REPORTED THAT A
CANDIDATE THAT SHOWED ANGER
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WOULD ATTEND RALLIES OR
VOTES ON ELECTION DAY.
RESEARCHERS WARNED THAT MAKING
SUPPORTERS ANGRY WORKS IN THE
SHORT-TERM, BUT AS THE NEGATIVE
LONG-TERM CONSEQUENCES OF MAKING
EVERYONE HATE EACH OTHER.
VOTER I.D. LAWS ARE THE WORST
THINGS WITH THE CIVIL WAR COULD
LEAVE TWO OF SILVERWARE.
WHICH IS AWESOME, BECAUSE I LOVE
SEQUELS, EMILY.
YOU OFTEN CURSE AROUND THE
OFFICE, YOUR REPUTATION IS THAT
YOU ARE JUST MEAN TO EVERYBODY.
BENEATH YOU.
SO HAS THAT HELPED YOU AND YOUR
SUCCESS?
>> FAKE NEWS WHILE WE'RE ON THE
SUBJECT OF SEQUELS, REALLY
EXCITED FOR TOP GUN 2.
SO HERE'S THE THING THAT STOOD
UP TO ME ABOUT THIS WHOLE STUDY
IS THAT IT ALSO SAYS THAT PEOPLE
STARTED TO ME AT THE ANGER THEY
SAW THESE POLITICIANS AND THAT
POLITICAL ANGRY RHETORIC STARTED
TO SPREAD.
WHICH IS WHAT WE KNOW, AND SPITE
EASILY.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE TALK
ABOUT ALL THE TIME, WHICH IS
THAT THE MEDIA STOKES THE FIRE.
IN FACT, THEY ARE THE
INCENDIARY, THEY ARE THE
BEGINNING OF IT, THEY ARE THE
SPARK THAT THEY THEN CONTINUE TO
AMPLIFY.
I GET THAT THE MAIN POINT IS IT
WILL DRIVE TO VOTER GAMES ON
VOTING DAY, BUT IN THE INTERIM
IT'S MAKING A WHOLE LOT OF US
PRETTY MISERABLE.
>> AMEN.
TYRUS?
>> YEAH, WELL, I AGREE.
WHAT -- OF COURSE WE LIKE ANGRY
POLITICIANS.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WE SEE ON THE
MEDIA IS ANGRY.
AND IT'S EITHER YOU ARE EITHER
ON THEIR SIDE ARE YOU ARE
HORRIBLE RACIST MISOGYNISTIC
PERSON.
SO POLITICIANS, THEY WATCH THE
NEWS, THEY SEE WHAT IS GOING ON,
AND THEN WHATEVER IS IN THEIR
LANE -- BE AS MAD AS I AM.
BUT IT WORKS FOR A WHILE, BUT
THEN THEY DON'T EVER WANT TO DO
WITH THE MEDIA.
AND POLITICIANS NEVER HAVE TO DO
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF TELLING
REAL PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING IN
THIS CONSEQUENCES HOW ANGRY THEY
SHOULD BE AND THEY NEVER EVER
HAVE A SOLUTION.
THERE'S NO CONSEQUENCES FOR
POLITICIANS AND NEWS MEDIA AND
THAT'S WHY IT WAS LIKE, WE NEED
TO START MAKING THEM
RESPONSIBLE.
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY SHOULD NOT GO
TO POLITICIANS BEAR THEY SHOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE [BLEEP]
THEY PUT OUT.
>> SO SHOULD NEWS NETWORKS.
TO SPEAK AT ONE >> CNN RAN FOR
YEARS ON RAGE.
NOW THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RAGE, WE KNOW WHERE THEIR
RATINGS ARE.
>> YOU ARE TELLING THEM THERE'S
NOTHING THERE CAN DO.
AND INSTEAD OF SAYING, WOW, I
THINK WE WENT TOO FAR.
IT IS, THERE'S NOTHING TO SEE
HER.
EVERYTHING'S FINE.
>> Greg: I'M SURPRISED ABOUT
THE STUDY BECAUSE IT WAS
CONDUCTED IN MINNESOTA WHERE I
HAVE YET TO MEET AN ANGRY
PERSON.
THEY ARE ALL PASSIVE-AGGRESSIVE.
THAT WAS THE ANGRY RESPONSE BID
I WILL SAY SOMETHING COMES FULL
CIRCLE BECAUSE BARACK OBAMA
LOVED -- HE RAN ON AN
ASPIRATIONAL MESSAGE.
THERE IS A CYCLE AND THAT COMES
BACK.
>> Greg: TRUMP DIDN'T MAKE YOU
ANGRY, HE MADE YOU LAUGH AT THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE ANGRY.
IT'S THE HAPPY WARRIOR THAT I
THINK WE ALL LIKE.
OFTEN LIKE JOE.
JOE, I GATHER BEING COOL,, AND
SMOOTH IS OF MORE PERSUASIVE
TACTIC.
>> I THINK REVENGE IS LIKE COLD
PIZZA.
IT'S BEST SERVED COLD.
>> BUT YEAH, I DON'T LOOK AT
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH ME IS
NECESSARIL